SPEAKER: Now I would
love to welcome
to the stage, both
Alfredo and Angelita.
Please join me in
welcoming them.
Could you both just tell us a
little bit about yourselves?
Angelita, let's start with you.
ANGELITA BAEYENS: Thank
you for having us today.
My name is Angelita Baeyens.
And I am the firm director of
program at Robert F. Kennedy
Human Rights.
ALFREDO ROMERO: My
name is Alfredo Romero.
I'm the executive director
of Foro Penal Venezolano,
which is a human rights NGO
that works in Venezuela.
And we assist,
pro-bono, the victims
of repression in Venezuela.
SPEAKER: Great, thank you.
Alfredo, through your work--
through your human rights
organization, Foro Penal,
you've helped over
10,000 people.
I had outdated data.
I thought it was 4,000.
It's actually 10,000,
which is incredible.
So you've helped
over 10,000 people.
Can you tell us a little
bit about your work,
as it pertains to the
restrictions on freedom
of expression?
ALFREDO ROMERO: Well, yes.
We have assisted more
than 10,000 people
because we've been
working since 2002.
Actually, we started--
or I started, myself,
assisting the family of one guy.
His name is Jesus actually-- or
was Jesus-- and 18 years old--
a boy who was killed.
He was shot in his head.
So at that time I thought that
was going to be my only case.
I though who cares?
I'm going to assist this guy,
because the family actually
came to me.
I can tell you the whole
story is longer than that.
But then after that,
a second family
came to me, and the third
one, and the fourth one,
or whatever.
And I actually
thought it was going
to end in 2002,
because I mean, I
wasn't used to assist victims
of a stage repression.
This guy was actually
killed in a mass protest
that happened in 2002.
And well, actually,
repression increased a lot.
And so, at this moment,
we have assisted
more than 10,000 people.
We're talking about the
victims of a [INAUDIBLE]
including people that has
been [INAUDIBLE] detained.
They are also forced--
disappeared basically.
People have been killed.
People have been tortured.
And the number has
increased a lot.
How we help them?
Well, we assist them
legally, but legalese,
meaning you could talk about
the legality in Venezuela
of the judicial system.
It's something that is not--
I mean, it is very
important for the world.
It's very important for us, but
for a government that actually
control absolutely everything--
to work as a lawyer is minimum--
a percentage of the
work that you do.
So actually, we do campaigns.
We do a lot of different
things in order
to increase the
cost of repression.
That's actually what we do
more than assisting legally all
these victims of repression.
So we hug, I would
say, the families,
and we help everyone--
the families, or the
friends, or whatever--
even looking for people
that are being disappeared,
so that's actually what we do.
But there is a very
important thing that we do,
and I realized that that was
extremely important recently.
We registered all the detainees
and victims of repression.
You can imagine and then
realize that if you haven't--
if you were in there,
registered and everything,
nobody would know how many
people have been detained.
And this is very
important-- where they are.
And that's a very
important thing
that we are doing right
now besides things
that we do with victims.
SPEAKER: And can you talk a
little bit about basically
how the organization has
reacted in the assembly
and creating awareness
due to technology?
How has your organization,
in the context of association
and assembly, reacted in
terms of restrictions on that
as well?
ALFREDO ROMERO: Well,
we live in a country
that everything is
being controlled--
freedom of expression.
I mean, it doesn't exist as you
know here in the United States
and in free countries.
So we don't have an
opportunity to go to the media
and talk about what we do.
Actually, that's something
that happened until 2007--
there was a very important
thing to happened--
that they closed--
the government closed
a very important TV channel.
The name was RCTV.
And I'm telling you about it,
because that channel, at least
I was able to go in and
denounce what was going on
and all the situation
that was going on.
At this moment, it's impossible.
You don't have a media
that you go and talk
about what is going on.
And the media actually
doesn't show what is going on.
They don't show when
somebody is detained,
or when somebody is killed,
or when somebody's tortured--
something that we do--
we do it by ourselves.
So what we do in order to
continue working, and showing
people what is going on, and
to increase political cause,
we use social media.
For us, social media
is extremely important.
That's something
that, actually, I
didn't know too much about it.
I started using
social media in 2009.
That was the first
student I actually helped.
He was just the first
student that was actually
[INAUDIBLE] detained.
His name is Julio.
I remember-- just to tell
you an anecdote about it--
he was taken to the court.
And this guy was 21 years
old at that time-- maybe 20.
He was very thin--
very naive.
And he was at the
doors of the court,
and I took a picture of him.
And it was in Twitter actually,
so I published it in Twitter.
I didn't know too much
about Twitter at that time,
but I used it.
And I took that picture.
I mean, all Venezuelans
saw the picture,
and they were all reacting
about this student that
was taken to prison.
And it was extremely important,
because after that, a hunger
strike started of
students claiming
for the release of this guy.
And actually, he was
released in 22 days.
And so, that was very important.
After that, I've been using
social media as most--
I would say it's the most
important tool for increasing
the cost of repression, because
it's not that you can tell it
to the world like easier,
because it's not that you
have the media there to--
I mean, the media
story Even they,
they're controlling
by themselves
because the government's
actually putting pressure
on them, or their government
just control the whole media
because they have all state.
You know, the public,
the channels, the media
is being controlled by
the government and state.
But so, that's the
way that we actually
show people what is
going on the world,
so this is extremely
important, the way
how we can work without
having freedom of expression--
the way of this
as you know how--
you know how it works.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
And you briefly touched
on, a little bit ago,
your work with detainees
and alerting the families.
Could you talk a
little bit about that,
what that looked like
before your work,
and what it looks like now?
ALFREDO ROMERO: We work--
I always say that we work in
the darkness and solitude,
because when there is a mass
protest and a lot of people
are out on the streets
and protesting, at least
you are with your family,
your friends, and all of that.
When we start working--
when people are arbitrary the
thing after the protest ends,
it ends because of repression.
What we do, actually--
people in Venezuela
know Foro Penal,
and they know that we help
people that are being betrayed.
But more than that, they
know that the only way
to know where their son,
or daughter, or mother,
or father was taken
is to call Foro Penal.
So what we do-- we were
more than 4,000 volunteers
right now.
It's incredible.
I mean, it's a very
big organization.
What these volunteers
do is not just lawyers.
We are right now formed by
more than 160 lawyers all
around the country.
But what the volunteers do--
the volunteers are the ones.
I'm talking about the volunteers
are a student, a mother,
or whatever.
I mean, even
volunteers were already
victims of repression
at some point,
so they help Foro Penal--
helping other victims.
So they go-- because when
you're detained, technically,
in Venezuela, your
force disappeared.
I mean, there are
forced disappearances,
because you don't know
where you're being taken.
It's not that you call
800-government for Venezuela,
and then you find out where
your son is being detained--
or your daughter.
So that's what we do actually.
We work at night
until the morning
in order to know where these
SPEAKER: --the
family members are.
ALFREDO ROMERO: No,
where the people--
the detainees are.
So the families call us,
and we tell the family,
go to that place,
because we have found out
that this guy's in that place.
So whenever we found
out, for example,
Pedro is in whatever place--
and how we find it out?
Well, because we talked to the
custodians there, and you know,
it's not like an official thing.
So we do it like underground.
So we talk to them.
Is this guy here?
So then when you find out
that this guy is there,
because somebody tells
you that this guy's there,
sometimes you find out
that there are 10 others.
So we start helping
these people.
So we tell the families.
We use Twitter basically
or social media to tell,
this guy has been
detained in this place.
So the families call us,
and come to the place,
and they know where they are.
And then the whole
process started.
So some of them are
taken to the court.
Some of them are not.
But it's more important
that, because you
have to provide food
to these people.
Because these people-- it's not
that you are being detained,
and you have food and water.
I mean, you don't have
even food and water
if you are not detained.
So you can imagine in Venezuela.
So you can imagine how
if you are detained.
I mean, you have
to provide water.
So you have to bring water.
You have to bring food.
You have to bring everything
to these people that
are being detained.
But it's actually
important, because as I
said before, you imagine
if we were in there,
nobody would know where
the detainees are.
So I've been talking
just since 2014.
January 2014, there
have been exactly--
till today-- 11,903
people that have been
detained for political reasons.
And we have it registered.
Now, we have a very
sophisticated database.
So we have registered
everything--
the place where
they were detained,
the age, the profession.
I mean, we know everything-- how
many women have been detained.
This is very
confidential information,
but we have
absolutely everything.
So it's not that we-- when I
said that there had been more
than 10,000 detainees--
11,903-- it's not because
the media tells me.
Well, the media gets information
from what we tell them--
or what we have.
So these are some of
the things that we do--
some of the things that we do.
Actually, we have a
kind of mathematical way
of analyzing the actions
that we have to do in order
to increase the political cost.
It's a kind of
interesting thing,
because we use a tactical plan.
I mean, it's not
something that we do it
right now as an informal way.
We do it in a very tactical
way of doing a specific thing,
so we analyze it
and all of that.
And I'm telling
you this, because I
was telling you about the
legal assistance actually.
The number of actions that
we have in order to release
a person is 40 actions.
So the legal assistance is
just one of the 40 actions,
so there are many.
And social media accounts--
the value for social media
is five of the 40 actions.
It's that kind of--
I mean, this is the very
methodology of that.
It's longer too--
I mean, there's a
long explanation,
but that's how we--
SPEAKER: Thank you.
And why have you chosen
to become a human rights
defender when it comes
at such a great risk
to your life and your safety?
ALFREDO ROMERO: I didn't
choose to become a human rights
defender.
The truth is, it will sound--
I don't know how it will sound.
But at the beginning, I
was graduated from Catholic
university-- a good
university in Venezuela--
Jesuit university and
owned by the Jesuits.
And then I came to
Georgetown University,
and I got my master's degree
in Latin American studies
from the School of
Foreign Service.
And then I went to London
School of Economics,
and I got my master's
degree in banking law.
So I didn't care
about human rights.
It's not that I didn't care.
I didn't know anything
about the human rights.
I didn't study human rights.
What I was telling before-- that
in 2004, one guy was killed.
He was shot in his head--
18-years-old boy.
His name was Jesus.
His mother name was Maria.
And I was, at that
time, an advisor
to the Supreme
Court of Justice--
to the constitutional
chamber to the Supreme Court.
And I was working as
a corporate lawyer--
still work as a corporate
lawyer with all the restrictions
and all that.
So as I said, I decided
to help this guy.
That's it.
I thought that if I helped
this guy, then it will finish,
and I will continue
with my work.
But then I realized--
and for example, right now my
friend and member of my NGO
and also part of the board
of directors, [INAUDIBLE]----
who is also my compadre.
And we started
helping these people,
and actually we realized
there were no NGOs doing legal
assistance pro-bono to these
people, because they realized--
I thought that there were a lot
of NGOs helping these people.
So I thought I
will help this guy,
and then an NGO will come
to us on and continue
with the assistance
of these people.
But actually, there was Jesus,
then there was another--
Jesus, [INAUDIBLE]
Carlos, and you know.
And now we have
Geraldine, we have Maria,
we have all these
people that actually
were victims of repression,
and they came to us
and asked for help.
And I became a human
rights defender.
And actually, in 2002, I
thought it was the end.
And then in 2003, I
And 2004, it was the end.
And now we're in
2017, and we are still
helping all these
people that are
being tortured with
electric shocks,
or sexually abused,
or were killed.
I can tell you many names.
There are already-- the families
of these people already are not
just my friends.
They are part of the Foro
Penal family of my NGO family,
because they have become
part of Foro Penal.
And they are not
just my friends.
They're my family.
And a very interesting thing--
when you start helping
people, you never know.
I mean, you didn't
want to do it.
OK.
But then you feel like a
need of helping another one.
And when you listen to them,
and they tell you of their story
about what is
happening to them--
and most of these people
are very poor people,
so they don't have money
to pay for a lawyer.
If they would have
money, of course
they didn't call us
to pay for a lawyer.
So you getting to-- you get
involved with all these people.
And when a mother
of, for example,
[INAUDIBLE] an
18-year-old boy student,
who's right now in
jail, and he has to be--
you know, he's sick and all of
that, and he's there in jail.
And his mother talked
to you, and crying,
and then you get
involved with it.
So you come to be a human rights
defender and to help people,
it had become an
addiction to me.
It's true.
I mean, it's like an addiction.
So I always--
sometimes I wake up,
and I say, OK, I have to finish
with it because I'm very tired.
Because, as I said, I
work in the mornings
and very late at night.
And I came to my house
sometimes at 4:00 AM,
for example, because
somebody called me
that he was being detained.
And so, I go to
the prison center
or to the military place,
where they are being detained--
or the police
station or whatever.
And then the next day,
I said, I'm very tired,
so I have to continue
with my work--
with my regular work,
or I have to you know,
I'm a musician also, so I
need to play music or things
like that.
And I realized after I sleep
a little bit, I wake up,
and again, I said
you have to continue,
because these people
are asking for help.
So in the end, it's not
that is a real sacrifice,
because if it were
a sacrifice, I'm
totally sure that I
will stop doing it.
It's actually a great benefit.
And maybe I'm talking too
much, but I will tell you
another little thing.
We have four principals
in the migrant section,
or what call the four C's.
The four C's because the words
start with a C in Spanish--
constancia, which
means perseverance.
The second one is compromiso,
which means commitment.
The third one is conviction,
which means conviction.
And the fourth one and
the most important one
is corazon, which means heart.
This is a very important
one, because it's not just
beautiful words.
It has a meaning--
every one.
And I explain to everyone
what is the meaning,
but the last one
is very important
because I explained it.
And I said what means
corazon or heart?
It's not just love
or a romantic word.
It's more than that.
It means that when you
do good things to people,
you will receive
good things to you.
And actually, I'm very
happy doing what I'm doing.
And I have a great family, a
lovely family, and nice songs.
And they appreciate what I do.
And this is just--
the family's very
important for me,
but well, this award
that I'm receiving--
it's not usual that you
receive awards like that.
But more than that, it's that
you feel very nice helping
people, and it's something
that, really, everyone
has to feel it.
Because as I said, it's a
very great indemnification
to your life and to you.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
So it sounds like one
thing that you thought--
or one incident you
thought was just
going to be the one
time thing, turned
into this whole series of
events that basically found you.
ALFREDO ROMERO: Yeah, I
get out of my comfort zone,
and I felt that
I will come back.
And yeah, now I'm comfortable
with what I'm doing.
So this is like-- right
now, it's my comfort zone
to be a human rights defender.
I don't see myself doing
something different
even though that I can.
I mean, I have to, because
to be a human rights defender
is not something that actually--
you have at least an
economic indemnification,
so you have to continue working.
And this is something
that I always
say to human rights defenders.
If we are to become
human rights defenders,
think about doing it, because
it's not that you will
receive a payment for that.
So you have to continue
working in what you do
and try to finance yourself.
And as I said, I always say
that whenever I help people,
I will always receive
something better from life.
SPEAKER: That's a perfect
segue to Angelita.
Angelita, can you tell us
a little bit about Partners
for Human Rights, and how
your partnership with Alfredo
came to be?
ANGELITA BAEYENS: So my
organization, Robert F.
Kennedy Human Rights has been
giving every year for-- this is
the 34th year that we gave this
annual human rights award that
was created to recognize
people like Alfredo--
the most courageous
human rights defenders
from around the world.
And the program that
I direct is precisely
a support program
within an organization
for those that win the award.
The award is not
only a recognition.
It's also-- we are offering,
as an organization,
to Alfredo and his
organization to really provide
all the support we can,
all the tools we use,
or expertise, or human
resources, or contacts,
or ideas to help amplify the
voice of Alfredo for Foro Penal
as well as the network of
[INAUDIBLE] that we have.
And that's what we
hope to be able to,
from now on, continue working
very much hand in hand
with Alfredo and Foro Penal,
knowing that Venezuela right
now really needs international
attention and the support
from people all around the world
to put an end to this situation
and this crisis.
And one of the areas
that, as an organization,
we've been focusing
more and more
is the protection of
civic space and including,
of course, the
basic freedoms that
make civic space possible--
freedom of expression, freedom
of association and assembly.
And by partnering with
courageous human rights
defenders like Alfredo, we try
to protect those basic rights.
Because in helping
those that are
on the front line like Alfredo,
putting their lives at risk,
their reputation, you know--
Alfredo, he didn't say so,
but he's attacked constantly
by government and by
sectors of society
that don't like him
being supportive of those
that are being--
whose rights are being violated.
And by partnering with Alfredo
and Foro Penal Venezolano,
we're trying to lend our
support and extend our hand
to organizations that
really are, day to day,
trying to protect the most
important and basic freedoms
that we all need to really
be able to participate
and to express ourselves-- and
have given to the people that
have been detained,
sometimes they are just
protesting for the basic right
of having food under table,
being able to work, or
being able to disagree
with the government.
And those rights are being
completely curtailed.
So again, we aim at
supporting organizations
that are doing incredible
work just like Foro Penal
Venezolano, and protect that
space that is so important,
and those basic freedoms--
such as expression [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER: So we are in a
very interesting time right
now, where there are a lot of
causes that could use support.
And so, what was
it specifically?
Because I know that there
were thousands of applicants.
What was it about Alfredo and
his specific organization that
led to the selection of the 2017
Robert F. Kennedy Foundation
Human Rights Award?
ANGELITA BAEYENS: Many reasons--
Alfredo was definitely the very
clear and unanimous decision
by the jury.
We have an external
jury that chooses,
each year, the [INAUDIBLE].
And with Alfredo, we saw
somebody that is courageous--
that has been able to
choose a different path--
and having had a different
carrier has made--
has received the calling of a
being human rights defender--
and has really fell
through with it.
And we also saw and see
that ability and to take--
the methodology that is used
by Alfredo and the Foro Penal
Venezolano, this idea of
really creating a network,
lending support that goes
beyond just the legal assistance
but also tends to
all the other aspects
and needs of victims of
human rights violations.
So it's a very
integral approach,
and it involves people
and your victims,
and families of victims,
and society at large.
So that was one of the many
special things that Alfredo
has-- and his leadership.
Also, even though there is no
independence of the judiciary,
and the government has absolute
control over everything,
Foro Penal and Alfredo
have not entirely
given up on the rule
of law and on the need
to use the law to defend the
basic human rights of people,
but at the same time, also use
all these other creative ways,
including social media, to
try to get the message out.
So that's another reason why we
thought Alfredo really embodied
the courage, and the
creativity, and the perseverance
that we look to recognize
with the Human Rights Award.
SPEAKER: So we've touched on
technology a few times today,
and the use of social
media to create awareness
on what's going on to
notify family members,
and to even just
get the word out.
So last week there
was a law passed
that gives prison sentences
up to 20 years if a post,
or if something on broadcast
television, or on the radio
is deemed as hateful.
In the wake of that recent law,
how can technology still be
used as something that can
help your organization--
and as a human rights
defender in general--
and I guess also the
impact [INAUDIBLE]
ALFREDO ROMERO: We have
always to, I would say, fight,
but we have all these
obstacles since we started.
This is a law that actually
restricts, severely,
these kind of expressions,
which are just expressions--
I will say expressions,
or messages, or whatever--
against the government,
because the government
is the one who
violates human rights.
They abuse people.
The problem with this law--
I mean, they call it
a law against hate.
But what the problem
is that they don't even
explain what does it mean.
I mean, what is a
message that actually
is included in this
law, and it will
be sanctioned or criminalized.
You don't know.
So it's under
government discretion
when it's a message
against the law or not.
That's a big problem.
But this is our
law-- our new law,
but they already
have been detaining
people for Twitter messages.
Right now, for example,
there's a guy called--
his name is Victor
[INAUDIBLE],, for example.
This guy's been in jail for more
than three years just because
of a Twitter message.
There is another guy
called Leonel Sanchez.
He's still in jail
because of that.
There have been more
than nine people
because of using social media.
They come to your
house, and they take you
out of your house, because
they can find out where
you have sent the message.
So the important thing is that
the whole world knows about it,
and they understand that they're
using these laws in order
to officialize or
legalize in some way--
to formalize, I would say,
political persecution.
But this is something
that we are used to it.
And we have to
continue doing our job.
They are very
objective in the way
that we're doing-- that we
are just telling the truth.
And of course, for
the government, that's
why they restrict all media--
all freedom of
expression, because they
don't want the truth to be
known all around the world.
So that's why it is extremely
important to be here,
for example.
I will say this
companies like Google
or international companies that
have access to, I would say,
people, and they
can tell the truth.
I hope that they can help
countries like Venezuela.
We are always more
and more restricted.
And sometimes it is
important, because I'm
totally sure that if you live
here in the United States
or in a free country, you
will say, oh, come on.
Why these are people are stupid?
Why these people
can be controlled
by a guy or two guys?
Why they don't protest?
Why they don't do
things like that?
Why they don't just
go out in the street?
Oh, people have gone out
on the street many times,
but have been killed--
have been tortured.
And when your son
is being killed--
16 years old-- 15 years old, for
example-- this [INAUDIBLE] guy,
15-year-old boy that
was killed, then you
think twice before going
out out of [INAUDIBLE]..
So this is important to
understand, because--
and this is also a very
important thing to understand.
You cannot take freedom for
granted if you live in a free
country, because you never know
when you're going to lose it.
I used to live in
a free country.
I didn't know.
I didn't even
imagine that I would
be involved in these issues.
I didn't even imagine that I
would become a human rights
defender.
I didn't imagine I will be
here at some point in my life.
It's not something
I was looking for.
But that happened,
and that's why
it's important for the
whole world to know,
and for the people
to be some kind
of interested in human rights
and in human rights abuses.
SPEAKER: And in thinking about
your partnership together
with the Robert F
Kennedy Foundation--
in thinking in the
year ahead, what's
your vision between this
partnership and even
the organization?
ALFREDO ROMERO: My vision?
SPEAKER: Well, for both of you?
ALFREDO ROMERO: We have been
growing, Foro Penal, very much.
We're, as I said, more
than 4,000 volunteers
at this moment, but
we are in Venezuela.
It is important to
internationalize
Foro Penal and the message--
not just the
message, the method--
the methodology that
we used in order
to increase the
cost of political--
of state repression.
And I think this
partnership, I have
to find out how we
will work together,
but I know that it is
extremely important
to have an NGO in an
organization-- dependent one
that can actually
help in putting
the message in the place where
it needs to be [INAUDIBLE]
And this is the way
that we need everyone
to know what is going
on and make people
interested in what is going on.
And actually, even for
our safety in some way,
because as I said, we work
there, like in the darkness.
And if you talk about
Venezuela, maybe you
will think, well, first of
all, where is Venezuela?
In South America, OK.
Let me see.
What is happening there?
So well, there is
a guy whose name
is Alfredo Romero with
an organization that's
working a system--
victims of the state repression,
so people have been killed.
People are being tortured.
Well, there's an organization
here in the United States
that actually can, in
some way, speak louder
and say that this is going on.
I mean, in case
something happened to us,
then we have someone here that
is at least putting attention
of what is going on there.
ANGELITA BAEYENS: Yeah, I
mean, for us, it's a privilege,
and it's an honor, and
we're really truthfully
very, very eager to help as much
as we can, including-- there's
many tools.
One of them, of course, it's
what-- all the advocacy work,
international work, I see,
that we can do around the work
and what is going on in
Venezuela and in the work
that Foro Penal is doing.
We also do international
mediation with cases--
emblematic cases that, before
international tribunals,
were cases that
are representative
of a wider, larger problem.
And for example, the law-- the
recent law that just passed
in Venezuela, it's interesting,
because it's just an example
of one of the tactics that more
and more countries are using--
repressive countries,
where social media
was like another
frontier that was not--
that was completely
out of control
for repressive governments.
SPEAKER: And it's so new also.
ANGELITA BAEYENS:
And it's so new.
So they're really-- by
adopting these type of laws,
they're trying to
also control that.
And so, there's a lot of
things to do there even
to try to combat these
laws, but there's
many aspects of the work and the
tools that we can use together,
including international
mechanisms
and targeted advocacy that
we really look forward
to work together on--
and just put the message
out, and continue
calling the attention
of the world
and what's going
on in Venezuela.
SPEAKER: So I have
one more question
before I open it up to Q&A.
So for the people here,
for the people that
will watch this,
for anybody that's interested,
how can people help?
How can people get involved?
Being in the United
States, what can you do?
What can you do to help?
ALFREDO ROMERO: We incorporate
everyone to our network,
so everyone can be a
member of Foro Penal.
So they can register
at foropenal.com.
And actually, this
is very important
because it's what I say.
Even if you work
one minute a month
as a volunteer saying something
about what is going on--
even if you just work
two hours, I don't know,
participating in an assembly
or in a forum that we do,
it is extremely important.
So as I said, everyone
is important here.
And we train people to become
part of our organization.
So that's a very
important thing,
because if you are registered
in our organization,
then we know where you are,
and we can, in some way,
send information.
I mean, it's extremely important
to understand what is going on.
This is the most
important thing.
How you, I will say,
not translate it
in general-- not
just the language.
It's how to make
people understand
what does it mean
to live in a country
that the freedom has been lost.
Even the children-- I mean, we
incorporate 14-year-old boys
or girls, and I listen to them.
This is the truth.
Well, I always say that
in order for anyone
to understand what
you say, you have
to talk to a 13-year-old boy.
That's the only way
that you have to--
that people can understand
what you're saying.
It's difficult, but
it is important.
So that's the best way
to support what we do.
And for example, I'm not
talking about lawyers of course,
not just students,
or intellectuals.
I'm talking about
singers, about artists--
SPEAKER: --using your platform.
ALFREDO ROMERO:
No, but everything
is extremely important.
I use, for example, music.
I'm a musician, so
I use music in order
to sing and sometimes to explain
where I'm doing with a song.
And whenever I, for
example, publish a song
either in YouTube or
whatever, singing,
I will get more views than
just talking about a state
repression and, you know, all
the technicalities of this,
of people being
tortured, or whatever.
So everyone can help.
I always ask people
to register to become
part of our organization.
And I'm sure that they
will do something very good
for people in Venezuela and
also all around the world,
where governments and
dictators actually
have the control
of people and needs
to control people with
repression in order
to keep in power.
ANGELITA BAEYENS: And if I may
I add, since we are in Google,
and Google is known for having
some of the most talented
people on the technical field--
communications field, I think
that putting that talent also
in coming up with
ideas-- particularly when
it comes to getting
the message out,
security is also a big
thing, not only for Alfredo
but all the people
in the network.
What they're doing--
what Foro Penal is doing
is documenting
human rights abuses.
That comes at a high risk.
So anything that can help
do that work in a safer way,
in a more secure way, in a more
mainstream way, it's always
going to be welcome in
Venezuela and in other places
in the world.
But in this specific
case of Venezuela,
especially now with the
additional challenges
that are being created
by the government
to really disseminate
information, that's also
something where the
brains that we have here,
I'm sure it can be
very, very useful.
ALFREDO ROMERO: You
know, just very quick,
there was also another story--
very interesting-- in order to
understand how, for example,
people in the world can help.
And again, telling
what is going on
and increasing the political
cost of repression.
Just once about
one year ago there
was a woman that was detained.
She was protesting or whatever,
and her name was [? Joselin. ?]
So she was detained
actually, and she
was taken to a military base.
And this guy from
what she has told me--
this military officer
starting touching her,
and she was like in an
office-- in his office.
And somebody started
knocking the other door.
There was a soldier or
whatever, and this guy
stands up very quick and
stopped touching her.
And then the guy came
back to the office,
and started yelling,
took her, and threw her
to whatever place.
I don't know.
And she said who are you?
Why?
Well, because the
social media is
with your picture, and with
your name, and everything.
And we were the ones
who were actually
publishing pictures
of her and her name,
so this is extremely important.
So this is the only way.
Sometimes you can--
and I'm totally sure.
And she says that we helped her.
I mean, if we weren't there
publishing the pictures,
I'm sure she will be raped.
So it's extremely important.
I mean, just if you mention
something in a social media
network or whatever,
it could save a life.
So that's how good you can help.
For example, I will
give you another idea--
something that I don't
care, because whoever
can do it on Google is a place.
For example, I
always have thought
on a map of victims of
repression in the world.
So there is no map.
So how many political
prisoners are in the world?
Nobody knows it.
I know it in my country,
because we have a register.
So it's important to know where
are the victims of repression
all around there, so people
can actually put their names,
so the whole world knows.
There is like a map of
something's happening here,
something's happening there,
and Google is a great platform
to do that.
SPEAKER: So now I want to
open it up for questions.
Does anyone have any questions?
Can line up on either side.
We can start with
you on the left.
AUDIENCE: Sure, hi.
Well, thank you for everything.
So at Google, we're also
a data-driven company.
And I see you're looking
a lot at your data.
I'm just curious,
have you seen trends?
I mean, with number of
cases, number of repressions,
and things like
that-- has it changed,
or is it only going up, or
has there been any change?
I'm interested about that.
ALFREDO ROMERO: Yeah, this
a very important question.
Again, how we work, or
how I analyze everything,
I analyze it as a cost--
as a political cost
benefit analysis.
That's it for repression.
So we are the
organization that actually
shows the list of
political prisoners
in Venezuela, just
to give you an idea.
So they use, what I have called,
the revolving door effect.
So when they incarcerate
someone, they release others.
And they incarcerating, and
they're releasing others.
I always said that there
have been more than 11,900,
whatever, political detainees,
so they are being affected.
I mean, the intimidation
effect is really important.
So everyone is
being intimidated,
so everyone is a victim.
So she told me that
one of her families
was a victim, so they called us.
And you can see all
Venezuelans around the world,
even, telling me the same thing.
So in order to increase
the political cost,
we have showed how many
political prisoners there are.
So for example, before April
2017, before the last protest--
mass protest has started, they
were 117 political prisoners.
Monthly, if you
see our statistics,
there were 100 every month.
They were not the same.
They were 100 with a
revolving door effect
that I'm talking about.
In July, because of
protests, the number
of political prisoners
increased to 676,
and we started saying
that there were 676.
Right now, after
that, we started
sending the list of political
prisoners to the OAS--
to the Organization of American
States in order for them
to certify the list and
to verify the list, not
for the government
to say, well, where
are the political prisoners?
Well, they're here.
So the OAS has the list,
so we have it here,
so we have the names
and everything.
Well, right now, the
government called us--
actually sent me a letter
asking for the list of people
that had been detained
in a violent action.
This is a list of
political prisoners,
so I answered the letter.
I sent another letter
saying, OK, here is
a list of political prisoners.
Actually, they used
the list, and they
went to all prison centers--
some of the prison centers.
Actually, the number
of political prisoners
have decreased to--
342 is the last one.
So every week they have
decreased the number
to about 11, 20, or whatever.
So they have to go
again to the 100 number.
And this is important
because this
is how you increase
the political cost.
This is how you do--
because the
government, they don't
want to have 1,000
political prisoners.
They don't want to have
600 political prisoners.
Well, they don't want--
it's not that they
don't want to have it.
They want to have it, because
it's an intimidation effect.
So they want people to protest.
They want people to say,
OK, if I go to protest,
then I go to jail, so I
prefer not to protest--
or I'm being killed or whatever.
So they don't care about
incarcerating people,
but they don't want
the world to know
they have political prisoners.
So they are the ones
who are showing that.
So that's why I was
telling you about this map.
Because if a
country in the world
knows that the map
shows that they
have 100 political
prisoners, they will like--
better not to have
anyone if nobody knows.
For example, in Egypt, I was
talking once to a human rights
defender there, and I asked her,
how many political prisoners
do you have in Egypt?
I'm talking about Egypt,
because Egypt is not
a socialist country.
It doesn't matter if you are
socialist, or capitalist,
or whatever.
It doesn't matter.
Political prisoners
or repression
can happen in a
socialist country
or in a capitalist country.
And she told me, I don't know.
I don't know.
10,000.
20,000.
And she asked me, and I said we
have dot dot dot the number--
a specific number.
And then I realized,
OK, this is how you--
this is the methodology to
release political prisoners,
or to stop repression, or to
decrease state repression.
Well, that's why I think.
I don't know if I answered
your question specifically,
but I think that's the
most important thing
that, actually, we do.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Well, thanks
for your question.
So I just want to
end on, actually,
a quote from Robert F. Kennedy.
It reads, "it's from the
numberless diverse acts
of courage and belief that
human history is shaped."
So thank you both
for your courage,
and thank you for
everything that you do,
being here today.
ALFREDO ROMERO:
Thank you so much.
SPEAKER: Thank you
all for coming.